Trascrizione: Lorenzo Vitali
Revisore: Matteo Maggiò
Potete guardarmi
come una sorta di “Last Man in the Moon”,
come l’ultimo dei Mohicani,
un esemplare di una specie
in via di estinzione.
Lui forse può capire.
Io sono uno di quei 50.000 abitanti
di Venezia.
Tenacemente abbarbicati a quell’isola,
a quella grande isola.
Ma non solo di quei 50.000 abitanti.
Io faccio parte dei 4500
che popolano Murano.
L'isola del vetro per antonomasia.
Un’isola che
ha sempre connotato il suo nome
a quella che è la tecnica vetraria.
Io sono un maestro vetraio,
discendente di una famiglia che da secoli
trasmette questa antichissima tecnica
della pittura su vetro, su foglia d’oro.
E continuo.
Forse sono l’ultimo di una generazione che
doveva spiegare
se non sceglievo di fare il vetro
perchè, essendo nato a Murano,
non facevo il vetro.
Questa immagine vi mostra
la Murano del 1700.
Quelle crocette che vedete
sono tutte chiese, conventi, cappelle
19, le conto io per voi, 19.
Prima della caduta della Repubblica di
Venezia c’erano 19 chiese
e adesso, di funzionanti,
ne sono rimaste due.
E una fra virgolette part time.
Non si sono auto estinte,
sono state distrutte, straziate, depredate
quando Venezia crollò.
Quando Venezia nel 1797 venne conquistata.
E quella che sembrava una apocalisse,
quella che sembrava veramente
la fine di un mondo,
in realtà, non fu tale.
Vedete i “missioetti”
quei nomi delle vie,
quei piccoli lenzuoli
attaccati alle pareti delle case
ci ricordano cosa c’era prima,
ci ricordano cosa esisteva prima,
ed è qui che c’è la rivelazione.
Ciò che viene emanato dalla mente
passando attraverso il cuore,
la memoria e il ricordo.
Il ricordo di quello che era Venezia,
di quello che era Murano.
Due futuri presidenti
degli Stati Uniti d’America
John Adams e Thomas Jefferson,
e Benjamin Franklin
vennero a Venezia
per capire, per studiare,
non dico per assimilare,
ma per cercare di, quasi, di metabolizzare
l’organizzazione di questo stato.
Certo,
è facile vedere ciò che siamo
se pensiamo a ciò che eravamo stati.
E questo è molto importante, perché
il 1797 è stata un’apocalisse mancata.
Questo perché Venezia era un unicum,
era una specie di alieno sulla terra
un qualcosa con cui
tutti dovevano avere a che fare.
Venezia fu la prima della classe
nella pittura:
Giorgione, Tintoretto, Tiziano,
Canaletto, i Guardi, Tiepolo.
Fu prima nella musica:
Vivaldi, Lotti, Zarlino.
Fu prima nell’architettura:
Sanmicheli, Longhena.
Andrea di Pietro della Gondola.
Più veneziano di così .
In realtà Andrea Di Pietro della Gondola
era Andrea Palladio
E i due congressi
del Parlamento USA votarono all’unanimità
il fatto che
Andrea Di Pietro della Gondola
è il padre dell’architettura americana.
Venezia, fu prima nella letteratura,
nell’editoria, fu prima nel commercio.
Le prime leggi che tutelavano
i diritti d’autore erano veneziane.
Fu prima della prevenzione sanitaria,
i lazzaretti,
le zone d’attesa presero il nome,
oltre che la concezione, proprio a Venezia
e Murano faceva parte di questo unicum
perché Venezia aveva delegato a Murano
il ruolo di essere protagonista
nel mondo del vetro.
Murano non era un vetro,
Murano era il vetro.
E oggi?
Oggi sembra profilarsi
una nuova apocalisse.
Sono passati tre cavalieri.
Tre cavalieri terribili: L’Aqua Granda
che praticamente ha sommerso
le macchine, i forni.
Il Covid che
ha impedito una continuità di lavoro.
Non c’è nulla di più
prettamente a contatto
del lavoro del vetro
e il terzo,
l’aumento dei costi di produzione
Il gas sta praticamente
soffocando questa tecnica.
Sono tre i cavalieri che ho citato,
di solito sono quattro
e c’è uno che è quello più subdolo,
è quello che ha preparato il terreno
agli altri tre,
è quello che fa in modo che
quelle due bocche che vedete,
che sembrano mute
sono dei forni
in cui dentro non c’è più il fuoco.
Ed è il cavallo
del Cavaliere dell’Apocalisse
che ha fatto sì che il vetro di Murano
dovesse competere con altri vetri
con altre tecnologie,
con altri costi.
Non ha più lasciato che
il vetro fosse un unicum,
un qualcosa che era materia
che diventava l’anima,
che diventava materia.
Cioè ogni pezzo di vetro ha dentro di sé
una storia, una tradizione, una famiglia,
un ricordo.
Perché più della crisi, più di costi,
uccide l'ignoranza.
Si deve spiegare del perché Venezia decise
che tutte le vetrerie dovevano andare lì.
Si deve spiegare perché Venezia disse:
“Solo chi nasce qui può lavorare il vetro”
Solo così si può creare
quella sorta di curiosità ulteriore,
quella specie di richiesta che fa sì che
io vado lì perché lì trovo quell’oggetto
perché lì trovo
l'anima di quell'oggetto.
Perché il vetro non è solo materia.
Chiunque può mescolare.
Il vetro è il primo materiale di
sintesi inventato dall'uomo.
E come facciamo?
La storia.
La nostra storia è l'unica arma di difesa.
La nostra storia è l’unico scudo
contro l’apocalisse, contro la fine.
Ecco, vedete quei disegni di specchi?
C’è la sapienza di un’isola,
la sapienza di una famiglia,
la sapienza di una generazione.
Quel piccolo quadernetto che vedete
si chiama “Quaderno delle partie”.
Le partie erano le ricette vetrarie.
Non c’era una fornace che
faceva un vetro uguale all’altro
e non c’era un maestro che
faceva un oggetto uguale all’altro.
Proprio questa vicinanza,
questa commistione,
faceva sì che ognuno
voleva differenziare se stesso dagli altri
Il rischio è quello
dell’oblio della memoria.
Dimentichiamo chi siamo,
possiamo assecondare tutte le richieste.
Possiamo dire che il Ponte dei Sospiri si
chiama così perché gli innamorati
davanti a tanta bellezza (sospira)
sospirano.
Non è così.
Non è così .
Non è detto che la storia debba per forza
essere bene raccontata, bene inventata.
Si può benissimo dire la verità
e fare in modo che
quella verità diventi il veicolo
per cui milioni di persone vengono nella
nostra Venezia, nella nostra Murano,
a vedere cosa eravamo.
Sì, vorrei essere una specie di missioetto
che cammina, di toponimo che racconta,
che racconta, che racconta
perché è l’unica maniera che abbiamo.
Ecco, la ricetta per questo è fare
ciò che di profondamente significativo è
l'Apocalisse, la rivelazione.
Voglio rivelare.
Voglio parlare di quello che c'era.
Voglio dire che quell’isola invisibile
di cui nessuno chiede più
è presente, è radicata
è presente in ciascuno di noi,
in ciascuno di coloro che abita
la laguna di Venezia e l’isola di Murano.
Sì , nella presentazione io
sono un direttore di coro.
Lo avete sentito?
Forse il più grande coro d'Europa.
300 persone.
E’ questo che è molto importante per me:
l’uso di tutte le forme d’arte per
poterle fare dialogare con loro
e poterle fare dialogare con voi.
Creare una propria identità
fare sì che la consapevolezza
di ciò che si è ti permette di ergerti.
Fai in modo che la tua diversità diventi
argomento di conversazione,
argomento di scambio.
E la musica ha questa peculiarità:
può essere malinconica,
può essere romantica,
può essere triste.
Basta mettere un qualcosa,
un simbolo davanti una nota
per trasformarla in minore.
Il mio sogno è questo.
Fare in modo che si può raccontare, che
si può ascoltare, che si può vivere
anche, forse, una musica
apparentemente melanconica, ma alla fine
alla fine si toglie la nota minore,
si mette un accordo maggiore
e la musica diventa gioia.
Diventa un ulteriore passo in avanti.
Mi rivolgo a tutti voi,
specialmente ai più giovani.
Fate in modo che il vostro soffio,
come quello di Maestro di Murano,
possa attizzare il fuoco di ciò che siamo.
Possa fare in modo che quella che
sembrava un’apocalisse della fine
diventi l’inizio di una nuova era.
Grazie.